hello welcome back now let's return to
our top story around 100 000 civil
servants uh to go on strike next month
in a significant escalation of their
dispute with the government over jobs
pay and conditions the public and
Commercial Services union says its
members in some 124 government
departments and other bodies will walk
out for 24 hours on the 1st of February
it'll be the biggest industrial action
within the Civil Service in years let's
bring in the General Secretary of the
PCS Union Mark sawatke who joins us now
live uh good evening to you Mark Walker
thank you so much for being with us this
evening so why have you announced this
action now to begin on the 1st of
February
uh well good evening Kamali
um well as we've been I think saying now
for many weeks
um we represent the government's own
Workforce and the government are
treating its own Workforce worse than
anyone else in the economy we've been
given a two percent pay rise we've been
told tens of thousands of jobs are going
to be slashed and our conditions are
going to be cut
and we represent people who deliver
public services from cradle to grave
whether it's Universal Credit collecting
tax overseeing the minimum wage keeping
our justice system running our borders
open issuing passports we were clapped
by the government doing the pandemic and
yet now after 10 years of pay cuts we've
been told it's two percent and even
though the government know that 40 000
of our civil servants use food banks
forty five thousand of them claim
benefits because they pay us so low and
today it was revealed that tens of
thousands of our members working civil
servants will get a pay raise because
the national minimum wage is increasing
which tells us how lowly paid we are
despite everything we've tried so far
and despite action in The Border force
over Christmas with driving tests being
canceled rural payments as agency being
affected the dvla being affected they've
still told us not a penny extra so we're
escalating the strike Now by bringing
out a hundred thousand people across 124
government departments for 24 hours
there will be further sustained action
announced in the coming days and what
we're saying to the government is put
some money on the table and we can avert
these strikes but if you don't this
action will take place and it will
escalate further now Mark you've had the
mandate to be able to pull out your
members uh since November and that's my
point to why now you've got talks coming
with the government this coming week
with Jeremy Quinn
um you're demanding a 10 raise and uh
also an increase to living wage for all
your members you've had this mandate for
a while I'm wondering why now why you
called for the first of February what
has it got to do with the TUC National
rights to strike day
yes it has but but first of all Kamali
we believe in saying to the government
look first of all we'd rather talk than
go on strike when they told us no we
said to them okay well we'll start our
strike action it's going to be
significant but if you continue to
ignore us the action will escalate and
sadly despite thousands of members
already being on strike and causing real
disruption we know the security of this
country was compromised over Christmas
because Army Personnel are not trained
to do passport checks properly they
still are maintaining a position not a
penny extra and our executive met today
and we're conscious that there's
meetings taking place across the rest of
the public sector there's talks of the
government may be finding money to put
on the table for others and this is us
saying you can't forget your own
dedicated Frontline civil servants and
we've announced a strike but of course
the strike is three weeks away and if
the meeting with Jeremy Quinn tomorrow
gives us an indication that money is
available these strikes can be averted
but if he maintains a position of no
extra money for for people who are poor
the inward poor working for the
government at the moment claiming
benefits using food banks then he needs
to know that all of our members will
come out on strike there will be immense
disruption everything from driving tests
to passports to the ports and airports
benefit offices job centers right across
the UK will be closed and if he wants to
avoid that disruption he needs to find
money and start negotiating now you'll
know that Mr Queen has talked about uh
wanting to hear a fair reasonable demand
from you guys I mean I'm sure you've
done the figures how much a 10 uh pay
rise and that a raising of all work is a
15 pounder work living wage would would
cost the government
yeah the government claims that if every
civil servant was given what we're
asking for it would cost 2.4 billion
pounds but that's the way of the
government trying to avoid a sensible
argument we believe that if you get less
than the rate of inflation you're
actually poorer for going to work at the
end of the year than you were at the
start of the year and I cannot be right
but what we've said to the government is
tell us money is available and we will
get into talks and if there's
compromises in those talks let's see
what actually happens but at the moment
it is not a penny more and that's why
we're taking strike action if the
government come up with some money we of
course are happy to talk to them about
how that's distributed and how much it
is but we also want them to agree not to
cut tens of thousands of jobs and to
stop robbing civil servants of their
contractual rights to their pensions I
think that we can have a constructive
dialogue but it's only if the government
agrees to find money and Kamali I want
to make the point that even if it's true
that it was to cost 2.4 billion pounds
that is a tiny fraction of what the
conservative government was prepared to
borrow to give tax cuts to the richest
in this country so the government knows
it can afford it it knows if they give
us a pay raise our members will spend it
in the local economy boosting
manufacturing and the hospitality sector
at a time of recession unlike the rich
who avoid paying taxes and put their
money in the Cayman Islands so it makes
sense for the economy it's just and it
makes sense to ensure that civil
servants are not working but are in
poverty now Mark as you said this does
have something to do with the fact that
the TSC are having a national right to
strike day on the the 1st of February
and that is as a result of those minimum
service level demands that have been
brought in by the government
um that legislation is going to take a
while to come through but you said that
previous strikes for Border staff
security was compromised so so why is it
wrong to have a minimum service standard
in the in the Border Force then
well it's wrong because it fundamentally
breaches people human rights we have a
right to strike we're not slaves people
go to work and they have the right to
withdraw their labor and what we're
saying to the government is the answer
is not to conscript people to work it is
to negotiate and what we all know is
that if the government was negotiating
these strikes would not be taking place
but the answer to a dispute is not
increasingly Draconian legislation that
removes people's fundamental rights it's
to recognize that the government needs
to put money and Mark let me just let me
just pick up on that because you know
the government will say that the right
to strike is not going away they just
want to ensure that there's a minimum
service level so what's your answer to
that idea you said that security was
compromised by not having the right
border for staff on the borders during
the previous strike
yes but that was because the government
insisted on bringing untrained people in
to do the job of professionals and what
we need to remember here is people
wouldn't go on strike without a
grievance but of course the point of
strike action is that it has an effect
it's no good saying the government
saying you have a right to strike but we
don't want anyone to notice because then
people are losing money and they're not
putting pressure on the employers to do
the right thing you know the odds are
always stacked against working people we
already have the toughest laws of any
European country it's incredibly
difficult to have a legal strike now
what the government is trying to do is
to say well you can have your strikes
but they shouldn't have any effect and
that really undermines people's ability
to use the threat of withdrawing their
labor to force employers to be more
reasonable and whether that's the
government or it's a private sector
employer we supposedly live in a
democracy and in a democracy people have
the right to withdraw their labor which
is why we oppose the legislation but I
would remind you Kamali that we saw
leaked emails that actually told us that
government seriously considered Banning
unions and making strikes illegal across
large ways of the public sector they
chose not to do that in the end but they
only chose not to do it because they
thought they would lose legally in court
that tells us a lot about the government
it does not support the right to strike
it actually considered Banning people
from joining trade unions and that is
not the actions of people who seriously
want to compromise the last question
there mark this is going to happen a
huge uh strike action taking place the
PCS on the 1st of February on the same
day as the TUC call for National rights
to strike day as you'll know the general
Striker is very difficult to call but is
this the Stars that's what we're going
to see is this how you guys are going to
escalate this dispute by having this
kind of coordinated action big
coordinate election on certain days
I think that we're seeing an
unprecedented amount of strike action
we've seen action today by paramedics
there may be nurses we've already seen
our rail our post and our civil service
I think as long as the government
retains its position of refusing to put
money on the table we will see more and
more cooperation and coordination
between unions I don't believe we would
be the only Union on strike on February
the 1st and I think if the government
maintains its current position more and
more unions will take action together in
the weeks ahead okay Mark sawuck ahead
of the PCS students appreciate your time
listening thank you for being with us
thank you